When Donald Trump tapped into this idea
of make America great again
there there were there was times of
Economic Opportunity wages Rose until
the 1970s I'm proud to be a bartender
ain't nothing wrong with that
there's nothing wrong with working
retail folding clothes for other people
to buy
there is nothing wrong with preparing
the food that your neighbors
thank you
reubenon this is the Reuben report it
ain't nothing wrong with that brothers
and sisters it's April 13th in the year
of the Lord
2023 we are live streaming on the rumble
the YouTube and the locals we've got a
post game show as we do every day for
you over at
reubenreport.locals.com and I'm gonna
bust out this accent whenever I deem it
necessary to make a point you see
I want to make a point about the
accident real quick because a lot of
people enjoyed it yesterday that is my
fake Democrat accent and we have now
found so many videos of Democrats like
AOC and are called open just when they
go to different places and they talk to
different constituencies they completely
changed their accent it's the most
pandering dribble you can possibly
imagine so we've got a whole bunch of
Hillary ones and things that we'll show
you over the next couple days and weeks
but
the reaction to the accent that I did
yesterday was was overwhelmingly
positive but people said
it was uh it was half
preacher half preacher it was half Bill
Cosby and half Foghorn Leghorn now you
might say well that's that's three
halves Dave that doesn't make sense but
that's how overwhelming the reaction was
to this thing so it is a fine line
between Brie and a preacher and telling
people you must vote Democrat because
the Republicans are racist and then Bill
Cosby who talks like this you see Theo
don't vote for the Democrats or Foghorn
Leghorn I said I said girl boy what you
doing over there
I hope you're all proud of what we're
doing around here okay
anyway we got a big show for you today
uh you know this AOC chick I I really
don't like her I don't like her I don't
like a lot of these people try not to
get too bogged down and how much I don't
like them because I've got a good life
you know what I mean I got a good job I
got a good family I live in a great
state have good friends everything's
just fine but these people just do not
stop the endless insanity and they're
getting worse and worse you know lately
I've been telling you how they're just
not gonna stop and I think we really do
have to accept that it's important there
is no defeating the woke and this this
horrific collectivist mind virus that
has infected so many young people and
and you know rampaged through our
institutions and all of this stuff there
is no defeating them in like there's a
final battle and now we are done with
them they are always going to keep
encroaching on things what we can do is
protect ourselves you know build a force
field around what's good push them away
from our lives as much as possible
and build new things that they can't
infect right build better things than we
built uh over the last couple decades
because we maybe didn't realize or the
people before us didn't realize that a
virus like this uh could so infect the
host the way it has uh so today we're
going to talk a little bit about sort of
the modern Democrat blueprint which is
Lawless and crazy and I'll show you some
AOC Clips in a moment versus a winning
blueprint which really is just based in
some old documents that a bunch of guys
with white wigs somehow scribbled out a
couple hundred years ago so that's what
we're going to be doing today uh let's
start with AOC though because you may
have heard that last week a Texas Court
ruled that the FDA approval of the
abortion pill mifip pristone hope I
pronounced that right would be blocked
that they would not be allowed to sell
it anymore this is what the Court ruled
courts decide what's legal and what's
illegal this is obviously following the
reversal of Roe v Wade and here is AOC
talking to Anderson Cooper over on CNN
saying that we should ignore the Court
ruling which I'm pretty sure would be a
violation of the Constitution but don't
take my word for it here's AOC
there has been thought I believe given
to this Senator Ron Wyden has already
issued statements uh for example
advising what we should do in a
situation like this which I concur which
is that I believe that the by
demonstration should ignore uh this
ruling I think that we you know the
courts have the legitimacy and they rely
on the legitimacy of their rulings and
what they are currently doing is engaged
in an unprecedented and dramatic erosion
of the legitimacy of the courts they it
is the justices themselves through the
deeply partisan and unfounded nature of
these rulings that are undermining their
own enforcement so you're saying the
body Administration should ignored this
court but what does that look like what
does that actually mean you know I think
the interesting thing when it comes to a
ruling is that it relies on enforcement
and it is up to the Biden Administration
to enforce to choose whether or not to
enforce such a ruling
she is so unbelievably stupid that it
makes it hard for me to do my job
um okay couple things here first off the
courts rely on the legitimacy of their
rulings yes they do the courts decide
what is legal I'm going to give you some
standard old school
constitutional definitions of separation
of powers in just a moment
um that she would call the courts deeply
partisan
can you think of anyone truly can you
think of anyone in American politics
more deeply partisan than AOC right you
might say Gavin Newsom maybe it's a
trump on the other side something like
that but like she she is the very
definition of partisan the courts for
the most part it's not to say that
individual judges don't have their own
slant right sometimes we have more look
at the Supreme Court we have more
liberal thinking judges and more
conservative thinking judges but just
because you don't like the ruling of the
Court doesn't mean that you in this case
AOC from another branch of government
just get to ignore what that branch of
government did that's deeply
unconstitutional but and Anderson Cooper
knows that so his follow-up question
should have been hey lady uh you know
that's against the Constitution but he
kind of whitewashed it for her she
continued here with Dana Bash
you just heard me ask the secretary
about was something that you called on
the Biden Administration to do which is
just to Simply ignore the Court ruling
um that's a pretty
stunning position if you think about it
in the in the abstract about the notion
of just ignoring a judge's position so
my question is when this case is
resolved by the Supreme Court
should the administration follow that
decision if that decision ends up
Banning this abortion drug well you know
I I want to take a step back and and dig
into the grounds around ignoring this
preliminary ruling as well there is an
extraordinary amount of precedent for
this there is a term known as agency
non-acquiescence the courts rely on the
legitimacy of their rulings and when
they make a mockery of our system a
mockery of our democracy and a mockery
of our law as the as what we just saw
happen in this mythopristone ruling then
I believe that that the executive branch
and we know that the executive branch
has an enforcement discretion especially
in light of a contradicting ruling
coming out unbelievable that she could
call
the judicial branch making a mockery
what'd you say a mockery of democracy
she is a living walking breathing
mockery of democracy also the way Dana
Bash frames that question she basically
she says it's a pretty stunning position
in the abstract of the notion have you
ever heard anything more perfect from
just like a useless CNN anger in the
abstract of the notion we don't need the
abstract of the notion you are calling
for one branch of government the
executive branch to not abide by the law
that the judicial branch is passing
that's not the abstract of the notion
it's pretty flat out right in front of
your face
I believe at this point AOC by calling
by publicly as a member of Congress
publicly calling for Congress and in
specifically she's calling for the Biden
Administration the executive branch I
don't know if AOC knows this she was
confused about a few a few years ago we
have three branches of government I'll
lay them out for you in just a few
moments
um I don't know if she knows this well
she knows I know she wasn't sure a few
years ago how many branches of
governments there are but by her as a
congressperson in one branch of
government calling on another branch of
government the executive branch to
ignore the decisions of the third branch
through judicial branch I think she's in
a violation of her oath of office I want
you to listen we found it it's only 32
seconds long here is AOC taking her oath
of office being sworn in a couple years
ago and listen listen to the words that
she is swearing to abide by
solemnly swear that you will support and
defend the Constitution of the United
States against all enemies foreign and
domestic
I do that you will bear true faith and
allegiance to the same I do that you
take this obligation freely without any
mental reservation or purpose of evasion
too and that you will well and
Faithfully discharge the duties of the
office on which you are about to enter
so help you God
congratulations
does a woman who is now telling you that
she's going to have one branch of
government ignore the rulings of another
and and encourage a third branch of
government to go ahead and do that does
she seem like she is protecting her oath
of office to defend the Constitution
I don't think so also I recommend you go
back and watch that later and just watch
her body language and the blinking when
she keeps saying I do there is something
so deeply inauthentic about this LARPing
actress pretending to be the Socialist
radical uh for the record uh my call for
her to be there's no you don't impeach a
member of Congress but you can remove
them you would need two-thirds of vote
of the vote in your respective chamber
to remove a U.S congresswoman from
Office that's in the Constitution the
thing that she's not that interested in
protecting on usa.gov they do lay out
the three branches of government I know
you guys know this but in case AOC is
watching I thought we could make this
real easy for her AOC the legislative
branch that's what you're in as you're
part of Congress that makes laws so you
guys write laws out and you hope to pass
them the executive branch signs them and
that means that they're then carried out
the executive branch that's what they're
doing over there that's Joe Biden and
the judicial branch of evaluates the
laws they make sure that the laws that
you guys wrote that the elderly man
signed are actually legal we have this
separation of powers so that we have a
balance between these three branches of
government so they're constantly
checking each other right so we have a
situation where no Branch becomes too
powerful because uh several hundred
years ago the people who came to this
country and created these incredible
institutions wanted to leave people who
were controlling them Kings for example
King George you might want to Google him
and we didn't want uh taxation without
representation once we were here and we
wanted to disperse power and not have it
centralized even the White House the
official White House website you know
they're on the web right now they also
explain how this all works this is from
the White House federal courts enjoyed
the sole power to interpret the law
determine the constitutionality of the
law and apply it to individual cases so
that is what this Texas judge did now if
AOC cared about the Constitution which
he sort of swore to protect what she
would be doing is they would be
challenging this in court which they
will do and the hope would be that it
would for them would be that this would
get up to the Supreme Court where they
would make the ultimate the Supreme
decision on this thing but what she
wants is not to deal with all of that I
mean that's just a pain in the ass you
have to get all these people involved
what she would prefer is to whip up her
mob the Democrat mob and what they could
then do is force the president to just
not defend the Constitution she would
love that and Joe Biden doesn't know
what the hell he's doing so that would
be possible so
I think we sort of laid out a portion of
the Democrat blueprint right now you
understand this they get their foot
soldiers out there to burn down cities
when they want they defund police when
they want uh they constantly use the
education system to teach Shame about
America and teach neo-racism and to chop
kids genitals off and to not teach them
basic Civics so that the average idiot
that's watching CNN might watch that and
go oh you know I'm not happy about this
ruling with this abortion pill and I
agree AOC the president shouldn't
enforce that law I'm not even taking a
position for the purposes of this
conversation I'm not even taking a
position on the abortion pill or what is
legal or not legal this is what a court
said and we have to abide by the laws
and if you don't like it as I said
there's a system in place to have higher
courts check that out but the modern
Democrat strategy is to ignore the rule
of law and constantly and mercilessly
shove their agenda down our throats it
never stops and the problem with the
Republicans and I often say you don't
have to be a republican but you cannot
be a Democrat the reason I say you don't
have to be a republican is because often
more than not the Republicans only
deploy a reactive defensive strategy if
at all and we end up getting dragged
more towards the Socialist dystopia that
the Democrats seem to want there does
seem to be a surprise surprise here we
go there does seem to be one Republican
who is laying out a blueprint that one
actually combats what the Democrats are
doing and two I would say more
importantly paves a popular and
successful path to an act of pro-freedom
agenda which is actually what most
people want you know I spoke last night
at the young Republicans of Miami I did
an event for the young Republicans of
Miami and here in Miami a lot of young
Republicans happen to be from Cuba or
Venezuela countries like that so they
are either first second sometimes third
generation immigrants whose they or
their parents or their grandparents fled
communism their love of Freedom it was
such a wonderful night their love of
freedom is so deeply embedded because
they fled the crap that AOC and the
Democrats are trying to bring in they
are trying to import into this country
AOC whoever it was in her family that
came here you know her abuela who she
left in a rotting building somewhere uh
and then wouldn't you know the daily do
you remember the story what was it in
Puerto Rico right there was the
hurricane in Puerto Rico AOC puts up a
picture like a week later of her abuela
Grandma in Spanish uh in this like
rotted out apartment so AOC apparently
didn't do anything to help her the daily
wire guys how much did they they did a
GoFundMe for aoc's abuela a couple
hundred grand I think AOC wouldn't take
it so AOC don't even like her abuela
that much but if she can force the
government to take more of your money to
do what she wants with it then she's
cool with it anyway the point of all of
this is that we have one side you get it
they simply don't care about the rule of
law imagine if there where is an elder
Statesman amongst the Democrats where
where is Bill Clinton let's say who
should be the the Democrats he doesn't
have to be the leader of the party
anymore as an ex-president but he could
be an elder Statesman right now and
every now and again he could go boy you
Democrats uh can I do a Bill Clinton
accent boy you'd Democrats could we all
not have sex with that woman and also
can we abide by the Constitution of the
United States and let's not you know
infringe on one branch of government
just because we're doing another branch
of government that wasn't terrible I
could work on that one a little bit but
they have nobody there's nobody mature
there anymore there's nobody honest
there anymore they're all going all in
on this and then you can see they have a
media when AOC literally is calling for
a branch of government to ignore another
branch of government right that is
against the Constitution it is against
her oath of office Anderson Cooper well
like
and then Dana Bash well the notion of
the abstract remember these people are
all clowns so okay how do we remove
ourselves from the clown show you know
what we have to do we have to put people
in office who are clear and competent
and have a sense of what the actual
mission is uh I don't know if you've
heard of this guy Ron DeSantis here in
Florida check this out
what I see around the country with
Republicans is they started to develop a
culture of losing and it's almost like
this is something we saw it in Wisconsin
with this Supreme Court race we saw it
with a very disappointing midterm
elections in Florida we have a culture
of winning we have a culture of
execution and we have a culture of
delivering results and you need to be
able to win it's not easy when you stand
for the right things in this day and age
man you are going to have a lot of
blowback leadership isn't cost free
execution and delivering results what do
I keep saying we want Clarity competency
and communication that's exactly what
we're doing he's executing on the things
he said he would do one at a time if
you're watching this right now and even
for the for the Trump people that are a
little more annoyed at me at the moment
because I've been a little more critical
of trump and again I might vote for
Trump I basically like Trump I just
don't like the attacks but okay
tell me something if you're a rapid
Lefty you're watching the show or you're
a trump person watching the show tell me
something that DeSantis set out to do
that he has not done
he has gone ahead and done all of it and
by doing it and by not caring about the
polls just going ahead and doing what
was right as you know he went from under
40 000 vote victory in 2018 to over 1.6
million victory
in 2022 that's big that is big so if you
pick the fights properly you will also
and this is the other interesting part
you all know this there's a reason why
you're Democrat or lefty or liberal
friends are so crazed they're so crazed
because they're not connected to reality
if you don't understand the biological
differences between a boy and a girl if
you don't understand that this new
leftist racism is just a repurposed
version of Old School racism so many of
the things if you don't understand why
the Democrats run around pretending they
care about poor people but it's all of
the cities that Democrats run that poor
people have at the worst that
homelessness is the worst and drug use
and all those things they're so
disconnected from reality but what they
do but what we're nice but we give other
people's money to things we're very nice
so these people become endlessly
hysterical and speaking of endlessly
hysterical this is absolutely hilarious
this is actually incredible I honestly
thought it was a joke when I saw it
there is a non-profit organization here
in Florida called Florida equality
there's some sort of gay lgbtqi
two-spirit whatever organization and
they have issued a statement as of
yesterday this is this is powerful stuff
guys they have issued in Red Letters Red
Letters all caps it doesn't get scarier
than that that's the big one breaking
today we took the extraordinary step of
issuing a travel advisory warning the
risks posed to the health safety and
freedom of those considering short or
long-term travel or relocation to the
state
I want to be very clear about something
guys
if you are a Democrat or a lefty or
liberal take their advice
take their advice don't come here we've
got this thing called Freedom you make
up your own mind when you wake up in the
morning on how you want to live and
they're not going to lock in your house
here and your kids are going to go to
school and we're going to do it all
right here but I know that's scary to
you people so I really want you to heed
the warning of Florida
equality you know the funny thing about
it is Florida equality the group is
called Florida equality so I would
assume they want equality for all
Floridians which we have which we have I
didn't bother showing you there's like a
six tweet thread of that where they just
try to scare the hell out of everybody
once again guys Florida is not coming
for the gays and they are not coming
even for the trans or anything else what
Florida is do I don't even have to give
it to you you know what Florida is doing
and it's all good okay so what is the
solution for Republicans you know what
it is it's doing what DeSantis is always
doing which is don't look at the polls
just do the right thing it's really as
simple as that
my view is that I may have earned 50 of
the vote but that entitled me to wield
100 of the executive power and I
intended to use that to advance a bold
agenda I intended to use that to fulfill
my campaign promises and to do that I
resolved at the beginning of my term no
polls I am not going to just put my
finger in the wind and try to chase poll
results I'm going to set the rudder to
True North uh and I'm going to do that
and I know there's all kinds of stuff
that happens on The Daily News cycle I'm
not going to let that divert me on our
off of course a poll can tell you a
snapshot in time but it does not tell
you what the results would be if a
leader sets out a vision executes on
that vision and then delivers results
leaders are not captive to polls leaders
get in front of the polls and then shape
public opinion and that's what we said
we would do guys isn't that what we've
been waiting for I know I show know a
lot of the Santa's Clips obviously and
I'm constantly talking about Florida and
obviously only a small portion of my
viewers live in Florida but isn't this
what we've all been waiting for at the
national level right like we've all been
waiting for someone competent and
functional and who's Above The Fray and
has a true vision and who can accomplish
it and has hired the right people around
them we've been waiting for this person
now we'll see if he makes that step
towards the presidency but even if he
doesn't and I truly mean this even if
first off if he doesn't and he ends up
just remaining as my Governor here in
Florida that will be just fine for me I
truly truly mean that I really do and by
the way last night when I was at this
young Republicans in Miami thing we did
a whole there were a bunch of questions
about it I brought it up during my talk
about the trumpet DeSantis thing
everyone agreed as long as we don't
destroy each other right now it's all
good there can be some fighting people
don't really want the the endless sort
of over-the-top attacks by Trump but
everyone's kind of agreeing and everyone
there in Miami was like yeah if the
worst case scenario is that Rhonda said
stays as our governor all right fine but
but the reason I show these clips over
and over and do so much about this is
wherever you live right now whether you
live literally in California or whether
you live in Kansas or whether you're
watching this from Sweden or freaking
Mexico
this is the type of leader that we want
that's what you want to hear right
someone who's doing the right thing for
the sake of doing the right thing and
then what happens the numbers bear it
out so check this out this is from
interactive polls it's a little
something on Florida registration over
the years when DeSantis came in so this
is November of 2018 during his first
election for governor Democrats had a
263 000 advantage over Republicans in
terms of registered voters uh two years
later that had dwindled to 97 000. about
a year later the Republicans suddenly
were up 43 000 and as of this month the
Republicans are up 454
000 which is a net gain of seven hundred
eighteen thousand registered voters in
four years so if you do the right thing
if you stand up for Freedom if you say
hey here are the 10 things that I want
to do and I went ahead and did them
people will reward you and then you get
a cycle that starts working you get an
engine that starts moving and you start
freeing more people and then what
happens you get crazy leftist lunatics
like Gavin Newsom showing up in Florida
telling people they're not free and
everyone looks at him like what the f
are you talking about and you get crazy
non-profit far-left organizations like
equality Florida warning people not to
come to the freest place in the nation
where nobody cares what your gender or
sexuality is we care if you're a decent
person and if you have something to add
to society we will freaking welcome you
and and as I did last night I credit the
OG Floridians who deserve all the credit
for doing it right so that the the new
people could come here and and be
humbled and awed by what you guys set up
for all of us and now it is incumbent on
us to fight for it so I want to go a
little further on this and then and then
we do have a reubenreport.locals.com
Community Q a how do you deploy this to
Santa because it's not just politics
right I've got a tweet here from clay
Travis you may have heard of this I
think I mentioned it as a throwaway on
yesterday's show
uh but clay says here NPR National
Public Radio announces it will no longer
use Twitter because Elon Musk has
correctly pointed out that taxpayer
dollars are used to support NPR it's
amazing how quickly left Wingers Run for
the hills when they actually face
scrutiny NPR should just build its own
internet that's how this works right and
here's the statement below from NPR
NPR's organizational accounts will no
longer be active on Twitter because the
platform is taking actions that
undermine our credibility by falsely
implying that we are not editorially
independent we are not putting our
journalism on platforms that have
demonstrated an interest in undermining
our credibility and the Public's
understanding of our editorial
Independence we are turning away from
Twitter but not from our audiences and
communities there are plenty of ways to
stay connected and keep up with NPR's
news music and cultural content uh well
this Elon Musk guy you know this Elon
Musk guy run Twitter he saw that and
here's what he tweeted
NPR literally said Federal funding is
essential to public radio on their
website now taken down what Hypocrites
so the point is guys whether it's
DeSantis doing the right thing in
Florida or Elon Musk appropriately
labeling NPR state-sponsored media which
they had on their own freaking website
until they took it down a couple of days
ago if you call them out and do the
right thing people start coalescing
around that that is the winning model
that's what we got to keep going with be
above The Fray I'm gonna do a I'm going
to try to do an even better job I think
I do a basically decent job of it but
I'm going to try to stay above The Fray
when it comes to some of the uh the
Trump DeSantis attack stuff because I
want it was very clear to me last night
being in a room with all of these uh
these good people
that we don't want to add fuel to this
fire and you know what's interesting I
don't know if you for those of you that
are offline a little bit more you may
not have noticed Trump has really
shifted his tone even in the last couple
days I think he realized that the
attacks on DeSantis are not working that
just screaming that he's a globalist and
a rhino it's not working so I think
there are good things that could happen
there because then have an honest fight
not like the crazy fight but the point
is and this is true for DeSantis it's
true for Elon Musk I would argue it's
true for me and it's probably true for
you if you make positive change you get
more popular and once you get it's not
because it's a popularity contest but
once you start doing the right thing it
becomes infectious other people start
doing it right and then a whole bunch of
us doing do it and then maybe just maybe
we could turn this whole freaking thing
around I think it's possible but let's
get to some of your questions
reubenreport.locals.com Community Q a
here we go uh cam says what are your
thoughts on the recent information
regarding the research of putting mRNA
genomes in Grain vegetables and fruit
fruit seeds and plants this will affect
cattle chickens and eventually humans
because of what they eat and what we eat
we could be receiving an injection of
mRNA whether we want to or not Glenn
Beck did a program on this topic on
Tuesday your thoughts so I read a quick
article on this the other day and I I
want to definitely do more on this for
sure but yes it sounds like mRNA uh
which is which is gain of function
research so they manipulate the research
they when they manipulate the research
well they do manipulate the research but
that's something else they manipulate
viruses to change what the virus is
going to do and that's how we got
coveted uh it does sound like some of
this is going into cattle feed and a
bunch more this is seriously dangerous
stuff and it is I would say like almost
everything else guys it is on you to do
the best research so that you know what
your family is eating what they are
drinking where the food came from
and it won't always be easy you know
we're trying to grow more food here at
the house now uh obviously in Florida
it's very easy to grow Citrus and we've
we've got mangoes uh we've got lemons
and limes we've got bananas uh we
finally now we have some tomatoes that
are really flourishing because we've had
a lot of rain here but like do a little
research on your own we have a really
intense water filtration unit right like
don't be so reliant on just that I'm
gonna just show up at the store they're
gonna have what I want because one day
they may not have it and what the days
that while they do have it you may not
know exactly what they're putting in all
of that stuff so uh we will focus on
this a little bit more and I'll check
out that Glenn clip uh Snow Baby Says do
either of the boys have teeth coming in
yet have you fed them any steak Justin
has the first lower tooth so the uh the
grunts and the kind of oh the teething
sounds and all that has begun uh but
more importantly than even the tooth
Justin stood up yesterday for the first
time he actually oh I didn't tell you
guys yeah yesterday he pulled himself up
and he's fully standing he can't just
stand and like you know just balancing
himself but he has now pulled himself up
standing now he he then yesterday he
started trying to go up the stairs a
little bit so we've got Gates everywhere
I mean I'm basically living in like a
Max five prison over here but it's all
good it's all good and the food ain't
terrible uh Joe Shepard says uh Michael
malice the Willy Wonka of politics I'm
so glad that that caught on I always
call him the Willy Wonka politics uh
recently released his new book the white
pill have you been able to read it
totally honestly I skimmed through it a
little bit but I did interview Michael
about the book maybe you didn't see it
we did that live at locals uh what was
it about two months ago or so uh so you
can check that out just search Reuben
report Michael Ballas on rumble or
Google and uh a rumble or YouTube
wherever or it's in locals actually and
then you get it ad free and complete so
there you go uh Margaret says hey Dave
what songs and Rhymes are you and David
singing for Justin and Luke to Spur
their language development which of you
is the more enthusiastic singer you know
David's become I'm quite a singer I
could never get I'm always kind of like
singing throughout the house when my
guys are gone like I'm just kind of
singing songs and you know I'm humming a
lot and all that kind of thing David I
could never get him to sing with the
kids he's singing all day long he's
doing a he's got his own uh lyrics now
to Puff the Magic Dragon he's really
extended that thing and apparently it's
not about smoking weed we also did a
little Googling on that that was a
misnomer related to meet the parents
remember uh with uh it was a Ben Stiller
and Robert De Niro it has nothing to do
with smoking weed apparently and uh yeah
who was it that did Puff the Magic
Dragon not The Mamas and the Papas it
was uh
who was it it was uh the three it was uh
come on somebody help me here
does anyone have a computer in this room
Peter Paul and Mary thank you apparently
they weren't happy that people thought
it was all about weed uh but anyway uh I
do like a lot of different like I've
been telling you guys I do like
different accents with them and I talk
to them in kind of funny voices one
thing that I do that Justin loves is
he'll just start making sounds like they
do this like kind of Babel thing and
when I put my hair but we do a lot of
that and yeah you know Candice says uh
Dave please start a cult just kidding
the preacher's voice is hilarious but
I'm doing it I can't stop myself my
brother-in-law and his wife got here
this morning and I was like Yay well you
got it I was just I can't stop doing it
it's in me now but just that thing that
thing that they do I mean that kid
it's another one of those things where
if the media was remotely honest
wouldn't the media be showing you that
here was that kid what's his name Justin
Pearson here he was four years ago and
he's this like sort of moderate
thoughtful interesting kid talking about
both sides of the aisle and this is why
I'm getting into politics he comes off
as uh what was his name in uh Fresh
Prince of Bel-Air Clayton who know who's
the brother Carlton thank you it's hard
to remember all these freaking things
we're under we're like inundated by
information all the time he comes off as
like more white than Carlton if you
understand the reference there and then
he's up there preaching like he's MLK
and it's like an honest media instead of
just repeating all this stuff would be
like what happened to this kid is this
is this who he really is like do you see
the the grift do you see the ACT but
they just can't stop themselves they
cannot do journalism journalists who
can't do journalism
Florida manchuk says I see the pendulum
of power acting more like a cat's cradle
than anything else I feel that what
we're seeing now is the result of years
of the far religious right trying to
assert control instead of everyone just
sorting out the good ideas from the bad
and learning to live together the
Democrats and their woke mobs have just
decided to go have decided to go just as
far in the other direction I do think we
need to gain control but I also think we
need to stop things from swinging too
far in the other direction if we ever
have hope for a sane world again what
are your thoughts on this you know
what's interesting
because what you're talking about there
is in essence you want some blend of
liberalism and conservatism right so you
you want conservatism like we should
conserve the old things that are good we
should know an honest assessment of
History we should understand where we
came from and why these institutions
were built and why we have say checks
and balances and branches of government
and things of that nature and then we
should be liberal in the idea that if
there is a group of people a minority
group that was being treated in in a way
that was less than anyone else we should
always be trying to to find those spaces
of inequality and fill them up with
equality and that's what we've done
right black people were slaves they were
freed they could then vote women could
vote we got marriage equality like all
of these things we've gone to every area
in society and in essence made sure that
equality was attained by all but then
instead of just closing up shop right
around 2015 we could have been like boy
we really did do it we did it in America
we did it and there's always going to be
people that are complaining about this
and that and there's always going to be
inequities in society and all that but
we basically as a society did it we
could have said boy good job everybody
like let's take a little break but the
activist class and this is where I think
the the LGBT Mafia really did such an
incredible disservice and led us to so
much of this they couldn't let it go so
now we've gone from let's say the gay
rights movement for 30 years which was
only about equality marriage equality
and not having to go to bars that were
literally underground speakeasies that
you'd have a have to have a code to get
in because otherwise you'd be arrested
or they'd be rated or whatever they
wanted to be treated as normal people
They went from oh we got marriage
equality let's now move on so we should
have drag queens twerking in front of
kids
and unfortunately most of us that are
decent people we don't know how to react
fully
to this Onslaught that's actually why I
started the show today the way I did
because there are ways to do it it's by
clearly having a message clearly going
out there and accomplishing what you
want to accomplish and then as I always
say you still have to mock these people
they're not going to stop but I think
humor is a great way to to stop them I
think that I mean that's why I was doing
the accent yesterday and some of the
stuff that I do on the show it's like if
we mock them expose them for the
ridiculousness
hopefully that'll help but yes and also
by the way if you remember when I
finally supported Trump way back when
for the last election when was that so
that was like you know a year and a half
ago or whatever it was two years ago at
this point I guess it was even more than
that like it's been a while now what I
kept saying was he was defending
liberalism and conservatism it was
obvious how he was defending
conservatism with the Supreme Court
judges and things of that nature and
then he was defending liberalism because
he didn't care about the social issues
that much and he was a New York City
businessman he was the chance to kind of
have both and look what they did to him
uh Charlie says the alphabet Mafia and
the Machine now think it is a gotcha to
ask someone who has called out the woke
garbage to Define woke I have my
thoughts on the definition but I was
genuinely curious how would you define
it look very simply
it is equity over equality it is final
outcome equal outcome for everybody
rather than equal opportunity for
everybody and then usually that's
attached to a racial or sexual lens and
that's really it that we should
re-jigger Society based on immutable
characteristics and have everyone be
exactly the same at all times as Kamala
Harris said in that video the day before
the election we will all end up in the
same place well if you want everybody to
end up in the same place you're gonna
have to kill an awful lot of people
because uh it's sort of within the human
Spirit to go out and get yours and do
the best you can and that is why so many
of the people who end up as the the the
progressive lefties it's why they end up
miserable and it's why they look
terrible and it's why they're constantly
screaming and angry about everything
because it is anti-human to have us all
be the same we are all Unique
Individuals right the ultimate minority
is the individual I read and when you
accept that and you go oh I have
something worthy in me somewhere and I
have some autonomy over my life and I
might be able to accomplish something if
I go out and do it that's the scariest
thing for the people that want to
control you and sometimes it can be the
scariest thing for you yourself but
trust me it's better than the
alternative Amy Says in your opinion
what U.S politician or world leader has
been the biggest disappointment in the
last three years look the easy way to
answer this is Biden because Biden
I should probably come up with a more
creative answers for this but but truly
it's Biden because
I Biden was positioned as the moderate
right so the whole idea was we're not
going to go bananas with Bernie right
people to judge turning to Bernie on the
debate stage you want to burn it all
down I don't
so we're gonna all back bite it and the
hope I think for sane people is Biden
will will stem the tide on some of this
crazy stuff the reason he's been
disappointing
is because he has actually ushered in
all of this stuff now it's hard to pin
that on him because he's so mentally
compromised and he's obviously not uh
you know piloting the plane steering the
ship whatever analogy you want to use so
I can almost not even fully blame him
for all of that at this point
um
but it's it's disappointing I I mean
look we saw it right I'm guessing you
probably saw it but that was what
mainstream told us oh there the
Democrats are going with the moderate
guy but but what could be more radical
than what these people have done the
inflation reduction act we will
literally print money to stop inflation
which only has increased inflation like
everything they have done has been wrong
the war not war in Ukraine the the
withdrawal from Afghanistan the bank
bailouts like every single thing that
they have done is wrong so I would say
he has been the biggest discipline he's
also been a disappointment because we
all know this thing is fake and that's
dangerous
that's dangerous right if we all just
look at this and and young people see it
too I talk to my nephew you know he's 13
I talk to my nephew and he's like you
know he doesn't care about politics but
I'm like what do you think of Biden he's
like oh that old guy like what like
everyone knows this thing's not working
and it's fake and and
by golly I think maybe we can do a
little bit better intent uh Elizabeth
says hello from Seattle my God woman are
you in Seattle are you all right is this
a is this a call for help question are
you and David on the same page
politically and if so did you both go
through a similar transition from
Liberal to more uh libertarian
conservative you know we pretty much are
we don't talk politics that much you
know at the end of the day like I'm
usually not in the mood to talk politics
at all
um so we'd like to talk about house
projects or like what we're doing with
our lives or the kids or whatever else
it might be but we obviously do talk
about politics to some extent and he's
not you know he also is the executive
producer of The Show for many many years
and and really built so much of what we
do I'm just the guy that's on camera
doing it
um he's now stepped out of that and is
really focusing on the kids and these
these guys are doing great down there
um but in terms of evolution you know
it's funny in some ways he evolved a
little bit faster than me I remember a
day this has got to be around
2011 or so so probably about 12 years
ago and we were walking in New York City
and we were talking about credit cards
and he had never had a credit card
before and I was telling him you know
you probably get a credit card because
you want to build up some credit blah
blah blah and he could not believe he
actually I remember exactly where we
were on Columbus in 76. we're walking
down the street we're passing a uh
Dwayne Reed on the left over there right
by Sarah beths for those of you which
doesn't exist anymore because everything
in New York City is subsequently closed
but for those of you that know the upper
west right inside country and I'm
telling you you got to open up a credit
card so that you can build credit
because you know if we want to get a car
or this that whatever get a loan
whatever and he really could not believe
that people buy things if they don't
have the money for those things it was
like a crazy idea for him that why would
you do that and that became like a
running joke with us and then we started
talking about taxes and he's like well
wait a minute why am I giving the
government and I kept saying to you you
know you know you're a republican like
it was actually a joke between the two
of us and here we are in the Free State
of Florida uh Amy says what is your
opinion on what the priority is with
woke culture and politics does changing
our culture lead to better politics or
does politics and policy Drive culture
I'm specifically talking about world
culture d-e-i-c-r-t boys can be girls
Etc I feel like our attacks uh focus on
what culture only uh wait sorry I feel
like our attacks focus on woke culture
only oh only create more wokeness
because the left fights that much harder
creating essentially more wokeness I'd
love to hear your take on this sorry I
butchered that a little bit
um you know I think that's sort of why I
was starting the show today the way I
was and one of one of the reasons I've
been trying to talk a little bit more
about culture than just race horse
politics one of the reasons that I think
DeSantis is doing this so effectively is
he's picking the cultural fights when
they're the right ones to be picked so
the the Disney fight was absolutely the
right fight to be picked and then Disney
uh came back basically on their knees
and we got major concessions out of them
here in Florida they're they're fighting
those concessions right now and it's
going to the courts but like trust me
Florida has won on this and Disney lost
billions of dollars in revenue from the
amount of people that canceled Disney
Plus or don't want to take their kids to
the parks anymore and how hopefully
hopefully that will eventually translate
into the programming that they're
putting on so instead of woke Star Wars
they'll actually just try to make how
about I don't know good Star Wars
something like that
um so I think it's a little bit of both
right you know as Andrew Breitbart
famously said politics is Downstream
from culture so even if you have all the
right political ideas let's just say
you're watching this right now
and you think I am right about
absolutely everything and what I do here
is just completely true and you get it
and we're right everybody else is
schmuck and we're right about everything
we would still have to win some level of
the culture through comedy and music and
art and TV shows and everything else to
for to get people to understand that
right you really do have to do that
because not everybody cares about
politics but when I mean you see this
happen all the time this is why people
get red pills you get these crazy
lefties who are in college and the
government should do this and tax the
rich and then they get out in the real
world right they get a paycheck if
you're looking at that paycheck and
there's 18 different lines on that thing
you're being taxed for this in state
income tax and federal income tax and
this and all the other thing and you're
going boy I was I thought I was making
uh two grand a week here that was pretty
good turns out I'm only walking with 758
or just whatever it might be suddenly
they're like Boy tell me more about that
uh libertarian stuff and that's how you
get them on the path so I think it's a
little bit it's a little bit of culture
it's a little bit of politics and when
we can find a politician who fully gets
that and I think DeSantis is that guy uh
then you've really got something uh Lisa
says what is your biggest pet peeve this
is going to make me sound very old
I'm starting to struggle with the loud
music
Phoenix nodded a yes thank you you're an
old soul you two laughed at me I if I'm
at a bar and I'm trying to talk to
somebody and the music's blasting I
can't do it anywhere I don't know what
it is I cannot concentrate
maybe maybe it's this thing like it's
breaking all of our brains but I would
prefer lower music I remember when I was
in second grade
I had a birthday party at United Skates
of America that's what it was called it
was in Massapequa Long Island United
Skates of America it was a roller
skating rink and I had my birthday party
there and I remember my grandpa already
and he actually passed away a few weeks
later uh he said to me oh no he had
earplugs in because the music was
blasting and he was telling me that the
music's too loud the music's too loud
and I remember thinking this when I was
in second grade I really thinking wait a
minute this doesn't make any sense old
people can't hear right they generally
listen to the TV real loud but here I've
got an old person telling me the music's
too loud but I'm a kid I have great
hearing and I don't think the music's
too loud
what's that about it has something to do
with concentration or something like
that but anyway just lower the music
enough already with the loud music
crystal says
are there any plans to speak with Alan
dershowitz again I really enjoyed your
interview with him before Biden was
elected and I'd be interested to hear
from him again I know he's been out
there denouncing the people trying to
take out Trump but wondering if he still
has Rose Colored Glasses on when it
comes to Biden yeah I'd be happy to have
them on again actually why don't we go
ahead and reach out to him uh you know
when I did the Patrick bed David live
podcast on last Thursday a week ago
today with Rudy Rudy in here very good
friends Rudy is a conservative obviously
he is a liberal in that he's an old
school liberal and Rudy made a point of
saying that you know we've been friends
for decades we've argued about all this
stuff for decades and that's what
liberals used to be able to do now the
irony is that dershowitz is now hated by
today's liberals he said he can't go to
The Hamptons anymore because they all
hate him uh and because he's gone out of
his way to defend Law and Order he's
gone out of his way to defend due
process he's defended Trump on several
things and that's obviously the biggest
No-No for the liberal establishment so
it's a damn shame that uh that
dershowitz has been treated the way that
he has I've met him a few times uh
personally he's an extremely nice guy
he's obviously I mean a Harvard lawyer
like brilliant brilliant mind
interesting little thing about uh Alan
dershowitz he said that the best student
the most skilled oratory student and and
who had the best understanding of the
Constitution you know that thing that
AOC doesn't care about that he ever had
in decades of teaching at Harvard Ted
Cruz Mitchell
says do you have any dad moments slash
things you're looking forward to in the
future I mean I think I answered this
question once before but I cannot wait
to get these kids on the basketball
court like I think about it all the time
and even when Justin stood up yesterday
like suddenly I saw him in a different
way and I was like I cannot wait to that
day when I can get him out there and you
know he's gonna basically dribble a ball
that'll end up bouncing higher than him
and we just start doing that and we'll
lower the hoops and you know all of that
stuff we also have a really cool uh
basketball hoop in the pool so that'll
be fun once we can get there and get
them in there and start soon actually
one of the things we're doing right now
we're getting it ain't cheap but we're
putting four foot glass around the
entire pool because you don't obviously
don't want a kid falling in there and
it's a little early we're going to get
them swim trained as soon as possible
we've been taking them in the pool a
little bit so far but obviously not
they're not doing any any real swimming
at this point uh Colorado guy says why
would the VP of Bud Light risk trading
out 20 percent of their their patrons
that most likely make up 80 percent of
their business that's a great point for
a much smaller demographic surely she
and the executive leadership realize
that this would not be a net gain in
business for Bud Light right you're
going to exactly why wokism destroys
everything we played that clip of that
woman yesterday she in essence was
embarrassed by the people she was a
wokster she's a lefty she was
embarrassed by the Frat Boys that drink
Bud Light she was embarrassed by the
brand that it had become and she did not
care if she was going to offend all of
the people who actually buy the product
because she doesn't care about the
product as as her primary motive in her
position if you are brought on to do PR
for Bud Light what you should be doing
is I want as many people as possible to
buy but like my own personal
feelings about wokeism or trans people
or anything else should have actually
nothing to do with that but these people
have done something very Twisted in
their hierarchy right they put wokism
and faux diversity and all of this
nonsense at the height of that next
thing you know you're working at Bud
Light and offending all of your own
customers your point about that 20 of
the people probably brought 80 of the
beer is totally right and
congratulations now Bud Light Bud Light
is probably
irreparably ruined uh it really is you
know when we do parties here by Bud
Light anyway I try to buy as many like
small Brew Florida we got Florida man
beer we got uh we got what else do we
got what are the other Florida ones
there's like a bunch of Miami ones that
we've bought I know you like the
Lagunitas what else do we have
Wynwood Brewing Company yeah I try to
keep it local you know I'm more of a
tequila guy anyway but but there you go
uh Richard says I saw Rumble has the
exclusive streaming rights to the first
Republican primary debate where do you
see locals in Rumble in the future yeah
so I mentioned that yesterday it was
announced yesterday morning uh we
actually have all of the Republican
rights YouTube will not have any of them
uh I will also be broadcasting live from
all of the Republican debates we're
figuring out the logistics on all that
it is going to slightly complicate off
the great August because it looks like
the first debate is in August so I'm
gonna have to figure out how we do that
but we will be there for all of them
we're going to have a major Presence at
all of these things and really imagine I
mean really just think about this when
you take just if I was just to take you
know five let's say of the A-list guys
that are on Rumble right now you know
doing politics so if you took me and
bongino and Stephen Crowder
Glenn Greenwald and uh Russell Brand
let's say imagine the five of us on a
panel after a debate think how much
better that would be I mean I mean that
objectively I do not mean that
subjectively think how much better that
would be than whatever nonsense you
would be seeing after a debate on MSNBC
CNN and the rest so they're we're trying
to lay all the plans out on all this
stuff and stay tuned But to answer your
question uh we have major plans we have
major major plans you know the reason we
wanted to go public as a company was
once you go public you have access to
more funds so we're bringing in all
sorts of creators we've gone big on the
hip-hop Community The Gamers right now
we're bringing all of these people in
our live stream numbers on Rumble are
phenomenal usually at the end of the day
on a live stream we have about 200 000
views that's rivaling the roughly 200
000 that we get by the end of the day on
locals uh sorry on uh on YouTube plus
the people that are watching on locals
so it's like it's really cooking but we
have a lot to do it's not just replacing
YouTube and it's not just replacing
Amazon AWS
it's replacing Gmail it's replacing
iMessage like build out this is what we
want to do build out the suite of
products so that you are not the product
the product is the product and we don't
have to own all of your data and
everything else so because the people
will believe in the company and when the
people believe in the company and the
product is good the stock will rise and
it will give us more incentive to build
more good things there is a way to do
capitalism correctly and it ain't by
stealing your data and your soul and
then selling it to the highest bidder
at least that's what I think about that
if you have not subscribed by the way at
rumble.com Ruben report please go ahead
and do that if you want to join us for
our next Community Q a it's
reubenreport.locals.com we leave you
with a spectacular cold close of Elon
versus the BBC and we will do a post
game show in 47 seconds see you then
and I'm saying I say so that you don't
know what you're talking about really
yeah
of hateful content not even one tweet
and yet your claimed that the hypnot
content
[Music]
foreign